- Hi, Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
And I just wanna remind you
that as we get to the
final few days of 2020,
which has been a tough year,
I think for most of us,
there's also the final few days of our
end-of-year giving campaign.
And as we go through those final few days,
I wanna remind you that Khan
Academy is a not-for-profit
with the mission of providing
a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere, we
can only do that work
through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
And any way you slice it,
the social return on every dollar you give
is really off the charts for Khan Academy.
Think of the scale,
think of the tens or
hundreds of millions of folks
that Khan Academy reaches
in over 46 languages
around the world.
And if that by itself
isn't convincing enough,
I'll give you some of my
favorite recent research
that I've been looking at,
which is how do you
become a happier person.
And there's some things like
you should sleep enough,
you should meditate, you
should have gratitude,
but also do random acts of kindness,
and a very powerful random act of kindness
would be to donate to Khan Academy.
So not only will it help
others tap into their potential
around the world, millions
and millions of people,
I think it actually might
make all of us happy
by giving to it as well
and make you feel good
about strong way of ending
another wise tough year
and going into 2021 on a
very very positive footing.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy,
we wouldn't be able to do
the work we do without you.